hey it's Evan Carmichael so listen it's
really important that you support the
people in your network okay the people
have their own businesses especially you
know how hard it is to run the business
you know how hard it is to get new leads
to your company think about the people
around you think about their companies
and try to help them it helps you stay
top of mind and and it's not just doing
a good thing that you're helping them
out with you're also helping the people
you connect them to okay if you want to
grow your business if you want people to
think about you and send you leads you
got to think about them first set the
initiative so I recent got an email I
got an email today from a woman named
Shannon who wrote insane hi Evan do you
have any recommendation for social media
courses so it's on my on my phone here
and so I do some social media training
only two worksheets I'm not a consultant
I don't you know have a whole course pie
now that I have the worksheets of what
I've done and so I recommend those to
her but it sounds like she needs
something a little bit more in depth so
a buddy of my name's Shawn Moffitt runs
a company that helps train people how to
use social media for their business and
i thought i would give him a quick call
today i sent him this email but I
haven't heard back so I thought with you
guys on the line I'm going to give him a
call and let him know about this lead
and we'll see what he says so let's pull
up his website so his website is the
moffat company com and his phone number
let me dial this in here let's see if I
can copy can I just copy that
um yes okay let's call up Sean and we'll
see what happens I'm going to put on
speakerphone I'm going to let them know
that we're on the one on the air to this
is who were calling the Shawn Moffitt ah
Sean Evan Carmichael how are you how are
you listen man before we go too far I've
got you on speaker and i'm doing a video
you're you're on my video we're talking
about social media training and i sent
you that email did you get it yeah yeah
I got it and I responded to you ok ok I
mystic as I'm doing the videos now so I
just wanted to let the audience know a
little bit about you could you say what
you do about small training a small
business training for social media
absolutely I think social media
misunderstandings misinformation and the
cloud around social media how to use it
engage with when where why and make it
clear social media is about building
your brand in a 3d scalable regular
brand branded way and a lot of people
think social media is just you know for
people to talk about their lunch or the
weather or you know what the latest
thing with you know prince william and
kate pv is all about this lot it's about
about making money it's about connecting
with every single client or prospect you
could ever possibly imagine and
connecting with them communicating with
them clearly caring about the success of
their endeavors be personal or
professional in order to close
this and and be able to monetize it for
yourself and not every single
interaction is going to be monetized but
every single interaction does need to be
closed in order to deepen the connection
words of the relationship and have the
opportunity to serve later I love it
Shawn Moffitt on the spot nice listen
okay okay so she wants a small business
training do you have a training program
that you have on right now absolutely
i've got i've got a webinar program
that's on right now I've got some
customizable stuff and then I've always
got a mentoring program that's on the go
ray right now that I can always I can
always dip into plus i do customizable
stuff too so if there's something that
does she want that specific in and that
needs to be customized i can deliver
that as well okay and so I'll just shoot
you an email introduce you guys you go
you can take it from there perfect love
that alright thanks Sean will talk to
you soon thank you so much every [ __ ] no
problem man all right there you go Shawn
Moffitt live so reach out help people
right I'm gonna help this woman who
needs a training i'm going to help Sean
he's a friend of mine you know help him
grow his business as well so always be
thinking about the people in your
network and see how you might be able to
help them grow the business if you guys
liked the episode as usual thumbs up
below I always liked signals come in and
if you have a question comment always it
does below makes my day when I see them
come in thank you see you guys soon